Transcriber: Ruba Nammari
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
مرحبًا.
تقول هيلين كيلر:  “الحياة إما أن تكون
مغامرة جريئة أو لا شيء“.
معكم المغامر محمد راسم صوّان.
وأنا صغير لم أكن أستطع النوم
دون أن تروي لي أمي قصة قبل النوم.
هناك قصة واحدة ألهمتني
وغيّرت نظرتي لنفسي وللحياة.
هي قصة حقيقية
عن طفل اسمه بن كارسون.
عندما كان بن بالصف الخامس،
كانت علاماته الدراسية منخفضة.
لم يشارك في الصف وكان عصبيًا،
وأعطاه زملاؤه لقب الغبي.
وفي أحد الايام تواصل مدير المدرسة مع أمه
ليخبرها عن وضع بن
بأنه أسوأ طالب في الصف.
انزعجب الأم كثيرًا،
ولكنها كانت مؤمنة بقدرات ابنها،
فقررت تغيير أسلوب حياته.
وكانت خطتها أن يقرأ بن كتابين أسبوعيًا
ويقدم تقريرًا عنهما لأمه.
وفعلًا بعد عدة أشهر،
تغيرت حياة بن بشكل كبير.
أصبح الأول على صفه وهادئ ونشيط.
ومع نهاية سنوات المدرسة،
قُبل بن لدراسة الطب،
وأصبح أفضل جراح أعصاب بالعالم،
وحتى كان من المرشحين لرئاسة أمريكا.
وأنا أيضًا القراءة غيرت حياتي.
عندما بدأت الكلام، كان نطقي ضعيفًا
ومخارج بعض الحروف عندي غير صحيحة.
لذلك كان كلامي غير واضح.
وأنا في عمر الأربع سنوات،أخذني  أهلي
إلى طبيب لمعرفة سبب مشاكل النطق عندي.
وطلب الطبيب إجراء عملية جراحية
بسبب وجود مشكلة باللسان تسمى
تسمى باللسان المربوط أو “tongue tied”.
ولكن بعد عرضي على أكثر من مختص،
اتضح أن أسباب مشكلتي اللغوية
هي عصبية ونفسية وليست عضوية.
كان أمي وأبي مؤمنين أنني
لا أحتاج إلى أي تدخل جراحي،
وإنما أحتاج إلى تدخلات
علاجية أخرى لتقوية النطق عندي.
وفكّرتُ وقتها أنه لن أستسلم ولن أضعف،
بالعكس، تذكرتُ مقولة ستيفن كوفي:
“أفضل طريقة لتتنبأ بمستقبلك، أن تصنعه“.
وبدأت أصنع مستقبلي٠
نظرت الى العالم وحددت موقعي،
وبعدها قررت أن أنتقل إلى مكان جديد،
وضروري أن يكون هذا المكان في القمة٠
أتعرفون كيف؟ بالقراءة.
تتكون أدمغتنا من مائة مليار خلية عصبية،
وكل خلية ترتبط بالخلية
التي بجانبها من خلال روابط .
حسب دراسات جامعة هارفارد،
يكوّن دماغ الطفل أكثر
من مليون رابطة بالثانية الواحدة،
أي أن حوالي تسعين في المائة من دماغ الطفل
يتشكل قبل عمر الخمس سنوات.
لذلك أهم فرصة بالنسبة إلينا
لتسريع الترابط بين خلايانا العصبية
هي القيام بتطويرها
من اليوم الأول في حياتنا.
والقراءة هي أول هذه الفرص, فإنها تزيد سرعة
الترابط بين خلايانا العصبية.
بدأت القراءة الجهرية بعمر أربع سنوات.
وكنت أقرأ بصوت عالٍ وأكرر الكلمات والحروف
التي مخارجها غير سليمة عندي.
وفعلًا، كتاب تلو الآخر
وقصة تلو الأخرى غيرت حياتي،
وأصبح حديثي مفهومًا وكلماتي واضحة.
حتى كنتُ أعاني من تأتأة خفيفة
لكنها اختفت بشكل نهائي.
كانت القراءة بصوت عالٍ جزءًا من يومي،
كنت اقرأ لساعات بصوت عالٍ.
وأحياناً أكرر الكلمة أكثر من مرة
لتقوية عضلات النطق عندي،
وذلك للتعود على الحروف
التي مخارج نطقها صعبة.
واستفدتُ من هذا حيث طوّر
قدراتي العقلية وخصوصًا الحفظ،
أصبح أسرع وأقوى.
فبدأت بحفظ القرآن الكريم،
والحمد لله حفظته كاملًا.
(تصفيق)
عندما كان عمري سبع سنوات،
شاركت مدرستي بالتحدي الجماعي
الذي يسمى بتحدي القراءة العربي.
واستطعتُ حينها قراءة مائة كتاب تقريبًا.
وبفضل الله تعالى، فازت مدرستي
بالمركز الأول على الوطن العربي
بجائزة قيمتها مليون دولار تقريبًا.
(تصفيق)
وسنة بعد سنة، أصبح لدي شغف أكبر بالقراءة.
ولاحظ أساتذة مدرستي أن لدي معلومات
وأفكار أكبر من عمري٠
وفعلًا، أصبحت القراءة دوائي.
أثبتت دراسة أجرتها جامعة إيموري الأمريكية
أن القراءة تزيد من نشاط قشرة الدماغ الأيسر
المسؤولة عن اللغة
من خلال زيادة الترابط العصبي فيها،
وخصوصًا المنطقتين المسؤولتين عن اللغة؛
منطقة بروكا “Broca’s area”،
وهي المنطقة المسؤولة
عن إنتاج اللغة والكلام.
ومنطقة فيرنيك “Wernicke’s area”،
وهي المنطقة المسؤولة
عن استيعاب اللغة والكلام.
فالقراءة تنشط عمل المنطقتين،
ويستمر التأثير لمدة خمسة أيام
بعد الانتهاء من القراءة.
وأتذكر مقولة والت ديزني
الذي أسس شركة ديزني بعد عشرات المحاولات:
“إذا كنت تستطيع أن تحلم بشيء،
فأنت تستطيع تحقيقه“.
اليوم، أنا محمد،
الذي كانت أبسط أحلامه بالأمس
أن يتحدث بلغة سليمة مفهومة،
أقف أمامكم اليوم
على منصة عالمية مختصة بالخطاب،
بكل ثقة وإصرار لأنني تحديث الظروف.
وحاولت كثيرًا، فيوم أمس رسمتُ اليوم والغد.
ومع تحسن النطق عندي،
بدأت بتحويل بعض الكتب التي أقرأها
والتي تؤثر بي إلى فيديوهات
تحفيزية من إلقائي.
وأصبحت الأول في الإلقاء في مدرستي ومدينتي
وكان الجميع يحب الاستماع لي.
قيل لأرسطو كيف تحكم على إنسان؟ فأجاب:
“أسأله كم كتاباً يقرأ؟ وماذا يقرأ؟“.
القراءة؛
القراءة غيرت حياة الكثير من العظماء
وكانت مصدر نجاح وإلهام
لاختراعات وابتكارات عظيمة،
مثلًا، إيلون ماسك، الذي صمم صاروخ فالكون
معتمدًا على كتاب اسمه “Structures”.
ومخترغ تطبيق “جوجل إيرث“،
استلهم الفكرة من رواية للخيال العلمي
اسمها “Snow Crush”،
أو تحطم الثلج للكاتب
الأمريكي نيل ستيفينسون.
تخيلوا،  تخيلوا كيف روايات وقصص خيالية
استطاع أن يحولها
قراء طموحون لواقع واختراع٠
أثبتت دراسة في علم الأعصاب
أن القراءة بصوت عالٍ للأطفال
تحفزُ نمو المادة البيضاء بشكل منتظم
في مناطق اللغة في الدماغ.
أما الأطفال دون عمر الخمس سنوات،
الذين يقضون ساعتين يوميًا
في النظر إلى الشاشات،
يعانون من نمو غير منتظم بالمادة البيضاء
في نفس تلك المناطق.
طبعًا، لدى المادة البيضاء أهمية
في تسريع النواقل بين خلايانا العصبية
وتقوية القدرات العقلية والإدراكية.
لأنني آمنت بنفسي، حققت المستحيل.
لكن قصتي لم تنتهِ ولن تنتهي بسهولة
لأنني في أول الطريق.
وأنا مصمم للوصول إلى القمة
في كل المجالات الممكنة في حياتي.
من خلال القراءة الجهرية
استطعت أن أنطق بشكل سليم.
واليوم، القراءة بالنسبة لي
هي رحلة نجاح وطموح.
ابن عطاء الله السكندري يقول:
“مَن لم تكن له بداية محرقة،
“لم تكن له نهاية مشرقة“.
وشكرًا.
(تصفيق)